et maintenant j'accueille amusant de
et la pause bisous bisous
je crois
vous savez
bon sang
ça fait du bien
voilà c'était la pause bisous ça m'a
permis d'embrasser chahdortt djavann ce
n'était pas évident au début de
l'interview
tu va finalement oui ça va bien bien
puis vous avez trouvé pire que moi là
après dans l'émission que les voir bien
alors girardot bonsoir très heureux de
vous voir dans vous dites page 210 de
votre livre que le cinéma vous a parfois
oublié mais pas les spectateurs vous
dites je fais partie de la famille je
suis dans le coeur des français et c'est
vrai
alors le insee publié au cherche midi
ça s'appelle partir revenir les passions
vives et ça raconte votre vie annie
girardot
alors quand on lis ce bouquin qui
raconte votre vie on voit bien que cette
espèce de tristesse cette fêlure que
vous avez dans votre personnalité
remonte à l'enfance avec la mort de
votre père et surtout la la séparation
obligé avec votre mère qui était trop
pauvre pour vous garder auprès d'elle
votre frère et vous voilà alors
apprennent à vous raconter votre arrivée
à paris votre mère qui vous inscrire aux
cours d'art dramatique de la rue blanche
le conservatoire dont vous sortez avec
un premier prix de comédie classique et
moderne
votre entrée à la comédie française
votre éviction de la comédie française
parce que comme beaucoup à l'époque
voulu faire du cinéma et c'était pas
n'étaient pas compatibles
votre rencontre avec cocteau pour la
machine à écrire à l'odéon avec robert
hirsch votre rencontre avec visconti
pour deux sur la balançoire au théâtre
avec jean marais et là vous êtes choisis
par visconti pour le film rocco et ses
frères avec alain delon renato salvatori
renato salvatori qui est on peut le dire
je crois annie girardot l'homme de votre
vie et à papa de julie a bien sûr et
vous dites
la première fois que vous le voyez j'ai
failli m'évanouir a été beau a été beau
intégrant un j'aime bien les sommes qui
seront grands c'est le grand amour
d'annie girardot d'ailleurs vous coucher
avec lui dès le deuxième soir les
vieilles fiche n'ont jamais dit il manie
comme ça c'est important
bien sûr on accouche évidemment pas le
premier soir c'est ce que je voulais
dire
gentiane vous avez tenu une soirée je
trouve ça très bien mais tu es folle de
lui
c'est dans le bouquin créé tout un
il faut deux jours voire même trois on
vous dit angie radeau dès la première
seconde
il m'a marqué au fer rouge de la passion
renato c'est mon homme
mon corps l'a compris avant moi
fermez les guillemets fermez les
guillemets c'est vous dit il c'était un
animal sauvage une panthers certains
avis c'est le grand amour à ses 10
quelqu'un qui doit être très violent un
très violent et pour tout le monde d'un
seul coup il était très gentil à doha
mais si d'accueil avec quelqu'un qui
faisait quelque chose me rappelle du
tout foncer dessus on partait concocté
sur la route comme ça je suis plus dont
on allait de forte démarre mais je ne
sais plus quoi et à un moment il y avait
à ce moment là mais ce n'est pas signé
camion évidemment il arrivait juste au
truc qu'on va s'arrêter c'est le massage
le péage comme ça il ya un mât qui
arrive c'est toujours avec une espèce de
truc pour notre a grimpé de 21 à bord il
y avait eu peur parce on a eu peur à
temps mais ils sont comme est concerné
alors ce qui fait que c'est la toile à
bastia matinée un camion et procéder à
de la paix vous êtes barre et
heureusement parce que je n'étais pas
alors vous décidez de vous essayez de
vous marier avec renato salvatori vous
êtes enceinte vous de giulia donc en
fait le seul enfant vous ayez jamais
c'est à l'abri et la nuit de noces
vous êtes pratiquement obligé de le
violer parce qu'il n'était pas très fan
à des femmes enceintes étaient très bien
et donc ensuite c'est vrai qu'après le
mariage vous ne voyez plus pendant cette
semaine il est parti jouer au poker à
cortina d'ampezzo et ses copains et
côtiers vous ne lisez pas les hommes et
l'italien ah bon annoncé que le coureur
bien sûr il son label faut s'y faire
cesser cet avis quoi couvrir le jury
n'allait pas qu il ya les jouets way we
are and moi j'aimerais forte des
marmites et elle aime jouer au poker il
délire je sais que je vais souvent je
restais avec lui comme ça je regardais
et puis à un moment magique où ces gens
pouvaient plus y rester jusqu'à midi un
moment alors pas pièce coucher alors il
faisait tout alors que la paix la paix
ni qu'elle a commandés et alors à tout
ça m'a presque par sd tout beau pour
aller prendre jouer aux cartes et où il
était comme ça un beau coup de
séparation parce que vos métiers vous
sépare vous êtes souvent à paris et lui
avant c'est-à-dire quand j'avais à
travailler à paris oui hein mais m'est
arrivé d'être à rome
prenez beaucoup l'avion quoi je parle
des deux frères la vie on peut de toute
façon j'étais à paris puis amendements
calcaires j'aime aller à rome pour le
peuple et pour repartir le lendemain
parce que vous savez rome c'est bien
gentil quand il est pas là tu as des
cloches sa lentille t'emmerde
non yakov des cloches de bowling tu te
fais chier de major à paris
et alors on n'arrivait pas à base de ce
paquet alors moi je rentre la page
ouais c'est vrai que la dolce vita via
veneto c'était pas si bien que ça
finalement
ça n'existe pas ouais c'est monsieur
fellini c'est son talent voilà donc avec
renato salvatori l'histoire durera quand
même 15 ans et on apprend en lisant ce
bouquin d'autres aventures que je ne
soupçonnais pas ni gérardo jacques brel
vous dites ces mots ont marqué ma vie
avant qu'il marque mon corps je sais pas
ce que c'est nantes où classer cet homme
pourquoi ils étaient pas bonnes et c'est
comme ça et où il le disait et tout mais
il avait un charme et où je les ai
connus vraiment c'est en tournant
c'était
la bande à bonnot la bande à bonnot la
bande à bonnot vous dites en en parlant
de lamballe enbrel ses mains tremblantes
son visage creusé par l'émotion ses
lèvres moulié il était beau et je le
désirais déjà mes bras je vous dit à vos
souffrances quelque chose là bas je ne
sais pas qui avait si quelque chose qui
n'a crochet allez vous plaisait pas ce
que vous dites il éveille en moi un
désir physique que je n'ose l'avouer
dire qu'en fait c'est à dire que oui
parce que tu le vois mes du tout on a
vécu séparés de chercher là un ça s'est
fait comme ça et puis ça n'est pas faire
ça c'est fait ça c'était ben ça c'est
fait difficilement parce que un an après
le film la bande à bono il vient vous
voir place des vosges en appartement
vous aviez à l'époque il se passe pas
grand chose un petit flop avec des
choses comme ça très et il n'était pas
libre en fête c'est quelqu'un de très
honnête qui voulaient pas il était avec
une femme et à ce moment là il m'a
désigné pas été te voir là où tu tournes
mais parce que je suis avec une femme je
la loue bon je les ai très bien compris
vous vous dites en parlant de braine
j'ai qu'un regret un grand regret on
sait jamais dit je t'aime c'est vrai
alors il ya une autre aventure qu'on
apprend aussi en lisant vos ducasse et
lellouche avait pas moi claude lelouch
abou hein c'est vrai la caméra bouge est
tout le temps on n'a pas vu alors votre
histoire avec le votre histoire avec
lelouch été découverte par un paparazzi
dans un hôtel en normandie lellouche a
cassé la gueule paparazzi et vous alors
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est créé
nato salvatori à ce moment là il vous
fait une scène et c'était c'était
c'était une saisie du véritable vous
dire c'était pas du
alors on prend on apprend aussi votre
amour platonique avec louis de funès ça
c'est beaucoup plus étonnant alors oui
c'est une meyrin l'histoire d'amour très
pur vous dites un bain c'est un homme
qui va durer je l'adoré aussi on s'en
est pas rendu compte
ouais non c'est parce que on a fait un
film on s'en est pas rendu compte du
tout la zizanie et un jour je sais plus
madame de funès réclamer aux producteurs
en disant qu'il fallait lui donner une
soupe de gerbe de fleurs parce que on
avait il avait trahi
c'était un homme comme ça avec moi si
elle est folle les 18 ans je vais pas
dire cette femme en fait elle a su que
j'avais travaillé de funès comme ça
c'est un fait mais ce n'est rien du tout
alors rien de rien du tout alors je la
rassure s'est rien passé du tout
seulement cet homme quand tu voyais de
finesse la gentillesse qu'il avait et
avait un amour on avait un amour comme
s'il avait beaucoup de douceur dans le
regard qui fait quelqu'un je sais qu'il
m'aimait et sa belle volée mais un ami
vous racontez vous raconter aussi dans
les zones de votre vie bob decout
l'échec du spectacle au casino de paris
en milieu ouvert l'occasion dix ans
aurait cassé notre part et quand même et
au monsieur monsieur monsieur l'homme
n'est ce pas qu'ils disaient oui très
bien parce que nice est toujours tout
d'un conte oui je sais je sais ggg
conserver la façade non pas seulement la
façade monsieur le ministre
tout ce qu'elles ont toutes les îles
grecques et son l'escalier et sont les
skates merci c'est vrai c'est vraiment
là j'en ai marre non c'est vrai mais
enfin on peut dire oui on peut dire que
j'en faisais sauver le casino de paris a
confié par quitter valéo et renault qui
devait devenir du cac n'était pas au
casino paris vous avez sauvé vous avez
sauvé le que c'est notre pari qu'elle y
était si je les nie j'allais la boire je
sors mais elle l était
tu peux tu peux pas d'une non non non
j'ai rendu le vraiment le casino de
paris
on hamm est rien a pas marre on n'a rien
eu réaliste on s'est fait voler c'est
tout ce qu'on soit c'était sait plus
quoi les syndicats jean cyr ya je ne
sais pas tout ce que je peux vous dire
je n'ai pas tout vous hurlez payer très
cher alors que laperrière fait on a en a
pas eu d'argent on n'a rien eu du tout
sa mort je me suis sauvé la vie c'est
vrai je dis que monsieur je dis que j'ai
dit que bobino n'a pas eu assez de
chance donc vous raconter cette histoire
du casino de paris mais quand même il
vous dit ça vous a coûté très cher c'est
vrai que vous êtes est obligé de vendre
votre appartement place des vosges du
tout
c'est dans le bouquin ça va ensuite
annie donc traversée du désert et ses
lellouche qui vous permet un retour en
force au cinéma en 96
c'est pas vrai nous avons des
expressions que j'entendais pegi 3
lelouch devaient pas permis un retour en
force en 96 avec les misérables pour
laquelle vous avez attendu d'abord que
le loup su m'apporter tout quand hergé
j'ai fait d'abord vivre pour vivre
ouais je pense que il m'a fait 6 et nos
ménages qui m'a fait faire face avait
pas de tourner je savais pas un mec qui
me disait c'est comme ça je ne savais
pas d'un seul coup tu as histoire de bon
temps qui te dit d'être se couche mais
dans une réalité dans ce combat je me
marre j'ai un mec comme ça qui est pas
toujours senti qu'on prenait le prof au
quartier si le pape alors tu vas te dire
un montant entre tous
est ce qu'elle est donc lellouche vous a
quand même permis en 96 avec les
misérables de de revenir et d'avoir un
césar du second rôle féminin belle
apportant vient alors donc ça c'était
les césar et puis ensuite il ya cannes
en 2000 présentation de la pianiste de
michael haneke grand prix du jury est là
c'est terrible ce qui vous ont fait
parce que vous avez préparé votre petite
robe noire de ces versace avec laquelle
vous aviez films émissions de télévision
d'ailleurs hommage à brel et la séquence
avait été coupée et un petit peu comme
si cette robe vous porter malheur vous
n'êtes pas invités à cannes par l'équipe
du film
c'est dans le bouquin bah oui mais c'est
les ombrages de lierre raconte des
choses parce qu'à un moment je suis
fatigué ouais
alors j'allais tourner avec philippe de
broca et jean pierre marielle la non une
part c'est extraordinaire ça s'appelle
or vous savez que je disais prix de
branca je le rencontre il était d'à
l'abruti sa part dire que tu pourrais
pas tourné le corps avec marc et moi on
est vieux d'accord mais on pourrait le
faire quand même des buts un total mais
c'est pas de sujet des cinq ont alors
trouvé un sujet est totale
il a quand même retenu la leçon alors il
paraît que baisser depuis avec nous a
réussis avec jacques lamarque j'en viens
de marianne louis que vous avez initié
au nudisme l'île du levant
c'est à dire qu'il est arrivé lui las il
se retient dix ans et tout seul à lundi
après j'ai habité il est venu il est
venu avec son petit bateau je me
rappelle vous voyez qu'on lui a volé
d'ailleurs dans le train il a perdu il a
toujours un bel abbés trop différent de
celui ci est envoyé dans le train
d'envoyer huit mois vous aviez vous
aviez l'île du levant avec votre maman
depuis très longtemps
nos rabbins ont écouté euros ttc une
maman suse ou qui était un guerre alors
évidemment maman 6 ou évidemment on va
aller à légumes devant un robert et du
levant la première fois on n'y va pas on
racle bella tôt pour retenir donc on a
couché dans les grottes et tout
péninsule collet sait très bien que
finalement on est resté et puis avec
moment les est très heureuse
voilà et donc là vous avez invité à
l'époque tous vos amis dont jean-pierre
mariam c'est l'homme qui me fait le plus
rire on sait que le film allait alors me
et celui là le tueur retourne et avec
lui c'est quelqu'un qui est d'une
drôlerie et moi alors c'est vraiment mon
mec tout va vous rendre au cinéma tu
vois hein parce qu'on se répondent comme
ça que la qualité c'est extraordinaire
c'est sur l'île du levant vous avez
perdu votre virginité aussi annie
girardot dans quelques uns
lorsque avait il y avait eu une
tentative sur le couvre-lit de votre
maire qui n'ait pas marché
oui et en fait non je l'avais eu il y
avait quelqu'un ou c'était ça et ça va
pas marcher un épi là comme à ben ali
lui vends ma foi c'est une image avec un
père s'il y avait des scorpions j'avais
peur et besoins et puis ça s'est passé
très peur bleue vers 9h alors comme
j'étais très contente après tous